hi I'm Rochelle I'm earth where the
Bloomberg just been doing a session on
financial are two firms in them we split
it up into two blocks essentially what
are the like we have two trucks the East
Asia so he looked at the impact of
inflation the exogenous shocks of
sovereign debt crisis in Europe was
slowed down in the negative states and
it was natural disasters here as well
and how they play out in this part of
the world so what would the solution is
what would you recommend insurer and
beiges are people in terms of mitigating
that risk
well available to do dull alerts you
know but HSBC was adamant what we really
need is here to have deeper financial
markets and something raised with Jeff
riddle from zero financial as well
citizen but we need a bond market which
we mature bond markets also be putting
obvi and other people that said needs to
be in indigenous currencies in order for
them to actually work and actually
allows them to sustainability of
development and building infrastructure
which of course is another one of those
risks yet as it doesn't mr. chair truth
nor economic growth in this part of the
world also
well the vegetable is in exchange rates
as well more of that connected to have
natural attrition at your parents II
impatient business the intention work in
terms lowering inflation and that sort
of thing to me as well also talked about
of course that any possible slowdown or
even hard landing there in China and the
effect that could have as Indonesian
pilot which were saying well actually
we're not math dependent on exports may
not affect that much but of course there
is a huge dependence on investment in
this part of the world so really that
was aftershocks financial artichokes for
East Asia